Chris Pratt was on the show and and he
worked with you and he said that you
gave him terrific advice on handling
fame yes and it had to do with obviously
when people first get famous they they
if you're a people pleaser you try and
please everybody and other cell phones
people want selfies you have a very
Chris was telling us you have a very
simple response to the really simple
responses when people come up to me and
they want to take a picture sometimes I
will say not today baby
not today babe not right now baby
not right now bail of you yeah but I I
got a listen I'm doing handshakes I'm
doing hugs I'm doing smiles I'll do that
for you yeah the whole point is that you
know with people just want to
acknowledge you and they want you to
acknowledge them yes and as long as you
say whatever you say with love and
compassion and respect people will
understand right I think that works for
you okay you're Laurence Fishburne and I
think when you say not now baby not now
baby no baby I got to pump the gas in my
car yeah I love you I say that all the
time but I'm not standing near a car and
and when I start hugging them and
kissing them then they're very unhappy
I've got one God you got it maced many
times
you